[Music]  good morning goldie  [Music]  in front of warm dry gunfire mixed with  late afternoon stabbings sunday should  be warm and sunny just a scattering of  drive-bys great day for the beach but  not hitman's beach which will be mined  and sprayed with high caliber fire  medium coffee cream two sugars you know  it hmm who put a flavor grenade in my  mouth pull the pin thank you for making  this with such love you're welcome  officer johnny have a good one guy don't  have a good day  have a great day  this is the greatest cup of coffee of  all time i want to write a song about it  i want to dance to that song it's my  body i love my life it's about finding a  lane and just staying in it that's why  they call them comfort zones they're so  gentle  oh  joe  oh mondays am i right joe you said it  guy yeah  free guy rated pg-13 now playing only in  theaters  [Music]